Gill Collins I wanted to start this
because that was my experience instead
of reading the whole book because I was
traveling I listened to it what was it
like doing the audio part of all this
was very neat I'm a big fan of recorded
books and and and it was so it was a
real pleasure to be able to do a piece
of it myself and then to be able to be
the you know lead an act for Jane it was
very neat too you know
did you have anything to do with Jane
Alexander being picked to read it no I
was thrilled but I had nothing to do
with it whatsoever
so the idea for this book came from
where it just sort of popped up you know
we did that during the Millennium we did
a times issue of magazine on and women
over the last thousand years and they
asked me to write an essay introductory
essay and that was sort of the first
time I fixated on the idea of my god
there were theories about the way women
were supposed to be that went on back as
far as we can remember in Western
civilization and in my lifetime they
changed that's just amazing and so I
really the idea then I'm just going back
and looking at that whole story occurred
to me I thought of you when I read about
and I'd read part of it Sarah Josepha
Hale yeah I love first magazine editor
that was a woman you're the first woman
to be the editorial page editor of the
New York Times yeah yeah did you think
about that along the way is that one of
the things that moved you on to write
about this I don't know I think I
actually I was writing the book before I
became the editorial page editor I was a
columnist at the time it's when I agreed
to write the book and I'd written about
half of it before two years ago I got I
got this job and it's been terrible
trying to be the editorial page editor
and finish the book what Sarah Josepha
Hale story you know what I love about
Sarah Josepha Hale is she's sort of one
of those rope-a-dope women's liberation
movement people who figured out the way
to get what she wanted without breaking
any eggs without really upsetting the
theories about the way women are
supposed to be women were supposed to
stay home in the 19th century they
weren't supposed to do any of the jobs
that men did they were supposed to stay
completely out of the public eye
and Sarah Josepha Hale was the very
powerful editor of this major league
women's magazine and the way she did it
she started out she was a widow she had
five children to support and she kept
saying I really would rather be home all
by myself retired by the house Earth's
not not doing anything outside but
unfortunately I have to feed my starving
orphan children and she kept saying this
until she retired when she was 90 and
her youngest child was 55 but that was
still sort of the organizing principle
she was working on what was her magazine
in what year did she become editor she
started in the 1830s she started with
magazine called ladies magazine she was
extraordinarily prolific she went when
her husband died she started trying to
support her children by entering essay
contests and poetry contests she wrote
mary had a little lamb it never occurred
to me that anybody wrote me a little
lamb but she did I don't know she won
any awards for it but she started there
and then she got job writing this
magazine called ladies magazine in New
England which was like all the magazines
of that time basically just cut and
paste jobs you took a British magazine
and stole everything and put it out
again but she decided that her magazine
would be original and would speak to the
American woman even if she had to write
every word herself which she did even
the letters to the editor and then she
got promoted to goatees ladies magazine
dig Odie's magazine which was the sort
of definitive women's magazine at the
time speak to your own experience and
your job as editorial pays out of the
New York Times and a woman is there a
different way that you look at it than
say a man would probably my theory is
that people from different demographic
or historic backgrounds or whatever all
look at stuff a different way and you
can't say it's one particular way
because you're a woman but if you've got
a mix of a whole bunch of different
people running around doing things and
working together you tend to get just a
really good stew so I'm sure there's
stuff about what I do that's due to the
fact that I'm a woman but I don't know
exactly which things those are entirely
true what was the date of your new title
I came on
in August of 2001 so I had about a month
before you know why I came well and I
thought well this is sort of strange
because I was a columnist you don't
normally make a columnist the editorial
page editor but I thought well I'm very
good at kind of spinning things and
making things interesting even if
they're kind of pedestrian so it's gonna
be a really boring time in America
things look so calm the economy is great
Foreign Affairs are very dull so I'll
just sort of spin stuff around and see
what I can do with it and then of course
we've had one terrorist attack and two
wars a blackout a few weeks ago a worm
sent letters from our op-ed department
to thousands of people saying thank you
for your contribution when they hadn't
written any causing them all to believe
that identity theft did chicken rocket
taking place stuff keeps happening it's
been quite an adventure unless say can
you remember what you thought the first
day you walked in the editorial is there
a room that's you know people often ask
me if the times editorial page has ever
changed its opinion on a really big
issue and I always say yeah we changed
on women's suffrage for about a hundred
years The Times was opposed to giving
women the right to vote until the very
last minute we have a long boardroom
where I run the editorial board meetings
and on the other end of the boardroom or
pictures portraits of Charles Miller and
Henry Raymond who were the two really
major editorial page editors during that
period so I do like Jerry once in a
while come in early you know and say
guys it's Gail I got your job okay
wasn't Henry Raymond a Republican yeah
he was he was the during the Civil War
and he would legend had it that during
the Civil War riots he had a Gatling gun
installed at the in the department and
he was ready to shoot down the crowds if
they came and attacked the paper
he's a fierce-looking little guy I can
tell you do you have any idea who the
first woman was to serve on the New York
Times editor book and how long ago was
it it was in the 60s I think and I can't
remember right now who it was there had
not there had not been many really until
the until the 1980
how many do you have on the board now
and how many women are on there
there are 14 people on the board and
five of them are women no and but in 42
of them are on part-time right now
because they wanted to take more time
off to be with their families so we
don't have as many as a perfect balance
would indicate that we have amazing
women so that's good
when you did this research on women what
did you find were the three or four
major turning points in the history of
women's since night what is it 1600
since the 1600s one was the
Revolutionary War was just really huge
some women a few women thought certainly
Abigail Adams people like that thought
that they'd get out of the Revolutionary
War some really major rights for women
because they fought so hard themselves
they were the ones who ran the farms
while their husbands were at war they
were very active in the boycotts of
British goods so they really for the
first time there was a national sense
that women were sort of taking part in a
public event like the war was so they
thought they'd get a lot out of it and
they didn't legally speaking they got
very little there's that really famous
letter that Abigail wrote to John saying
remember the ladies and when you make up
the new laws drop the title of master
and take up the title of friend and he
wrote back which we don't quote in
school as to your thing about the laws I
cannot help but laugh at you Abigail
what are you talking about so they
didn't get that but what they did get
was the idea that women should be
educated that they be the mothers of the
new citizens so that women as well as
men should be sent to school and once
you started sending all these women to
school suddenly the nation realized they
had a terrible shortage of teachers and
every time in our history no matter what
the theories are about women if there's
a desperate need for literate workers at
low pay women are going to be it was
suddenly decided that part of the
maternal feeling of women was to be a
teacher so it was the first time for
women middle class women that you had a
job that you could go and do you didn't
have to be either a wife or a dependent
if you didn't want to get married you
could actually get a job and support
yourself and that was huge
just an amazing turning point so
Revolutionary War what's next maybe the
Civil War Civil War another whenever
there's a war all the rules are
suspended it's an emergency so there's
always a very strong feeling that women
are allowed to do stuff they normally
aren't allowed to do during the war
especially in the north
women were we're really very active and
before the war on the abolition movement
for the first time you had women really
getting out there and mixing it up in
politics again the women kept saying
well this is part of our maternal deal
you know it's not really about the
politics it's about families being
broken up you know Harriet Beecher Stowe
and Uncle Tom's Cabin was a very canny
rope-a-dope liberation way of looking at
that the slavery issue it wasn't about
politics or whether blacks should be
citizens it was about families being
torn asunder you know that and that was
the woman's issue so therefore the Civil
War was in part a woman's war and that
so many women got politicized that and
never really D politicized afterwards so
that was a huge deal and afterwards
again you know great disappointment on
the part of women who thought that they
would get the vote along with the
ex-slaves
and that never happened and there was a
sort of a very nasty evil period there
toward the second half of the nineteenth
century when people like Elizabeth Cady
Stanton were running around hanging out
with deeply deeply racist guys who were
really arguing how could it be that
these immigrants and these ex-slaves who
can hardly read are allowed to vote and
we middle class women aren't this is
wrong wrong wrong so it was a bad bleak
period in many ways next point in
history well you got to go for suffrage
is very big there's a great story at the
end of the suffrage moon you know it's
what you don't realize till you look at
it is how long and dreary and painful
this was there was a long period in
which the suffrage movement decided the
only way to do this we'll never get a
constitutional amendment the southern
politicians will never allow this we've
got to do this state by state so they're
slepping off five times they go to South
Dakota to try to get a constitutional
amendment in the south
good State Constitution and you know
it's always really hot out or it's
really cold out and susan b anthony
almost dies out there they're all
schlepping back and forth to South
Dakota and all these other very bleak
states trying to do this and it feels to
so many this one like it's never gonna
happen it's never gonna work out finally
you get to the point where you've got
you're almost there you've passed the
thing through Congress you've got all
but one state you're down to your last
state it's Tennessee it's the last
possible state it's the last possible
day it's passed in the Senate it's gone
to the house it's a one-vote margin and
the Speaker of the House changes his
mind and says he's gonna vote against it
and they're joking and then suddenly
this 24-year old guy the youngest member
of the legislature who's a no vote gets
up and says I've got this letter from my
mother she says son do the right thing
and vote for suffrage and a good boy
always listens to his mother I'm
changing my vote the thing passes and it
becomes law it was so dramatic at the
end I mean you would love to have been
there and what would you call the years
of suffrage the years the essence no
well the years that they did it was
debated and worked on and the susan b
anthony Zinn that you know you're
suffering it went for it it went for
almost a century and when you know Susan
B Anthony and Elizabeth Cady Stanton
knew they wouldn't see it they knew they
would not really see national suffrage
in their life get passed in Tennessee in
what year
if passed in Tennessee in 1920 and
became it's an election that the women
Lauren Harding they voted forward as far
as they know of course there wasn't very
sophisticated polling them but it
appeared that women basically voted like
their husbands did not I don't think
because they were following their
husbands lead but because like their
husbands their votes were predicated on
region or class or other stuff about
their demography that made them feel
that one party or the other was in there
and interest and of course Harding was
the great peace candidate of his time
normalcy but but it wasn't that a great
moment you know we begin this great
stride we were gonna change the world
the first thing we do is elect Warren
Harding the worst president in American
history so that's a little bit
embarrassing
the next moment do you think that made a
big difference again I'd have to go with
world war two I mean that but there's
this interesting but what you're seeing
during these periods if you look at the
top what you think is well during the
depression the whole gun country was
united and the idea that women should
married women should not work let the
jobs go to the men huge pressure for
married women to work thank in this
world war two huge pressure for all
women to go out and work big posters
saying men will die and more if you
don't go and man this machine tomorrow
then the fifties you know everybody is
supposed to go back into the kitchen and
it looks as if women are two sort of
dashing back and forth into the
marketplace but in fact it wasn't
happening during the Depression married
women who were working kept working
because they had a need to work and
during the war traditional housewives
who weren't working did not go to work
they stayed right where they were
and after the war married women who had
been working continued to work they just
didn't get paid as much for it
afterwards but you see that by this time
the women have really begun to set their
own rules quietly on the ground for what
they're gonna do and whether they're
gonna work or not so can we make the
statement that war was good for women I
think so
anything that shakes things up is is
over the long run good as unpleasant and
horrible as it may be when it's
happening is there a last moment then
where things really took another turn
well the the thing that knocks me out
whatever I do this and talk about this
or think about it is that in my lifetime
in the early 70s all the rules change
there was just suddenly this social
messy as it was very very fast social
consensus that women were not going to
be kept at home and that women in fact
had a right to do all the stuff that men
could do including having adventures
you know button playing baseball doing
all anything that a man wanted to and it
happened so fast it's just when you look
at history in one quarter of a second of
our history everything changed it's just
such a neat story I just love thinking
about it well then you point out that 55
percent of the graduates in college are
women yeah now how long did it take I
mean
back in the years we were talking about
her in a Revolutionary War how many
women went to school and any uh well you
couldn't even go to school but most
women were they were somewhere educated
at home or in private schools but for
the most part little girls there's these
horrible stories a little girls sitting
on the steps of the schoolhouse trying
to listen while the boys recite things
in any school now women didn't go to
school at all before um after the
Revolutionary War and in numbers they
started to go to school before then
there was a little bit of sort of home
tutoring and there were nannies who
would have like nursery schools of women
went to but there really wasn't any
education from when did they first go to
college um
they started going to college and little
numbers in the early 19th century in
small numbers a really huge sort of
massive movement of women into college
came at the end of the 19th century and
you had a period there that kind of new
woman period the Jane Addams period that
came after the turn of the century in
which you had large number of women
going to college large number women not
getting married
disproportionate to any other period in
our history and large numbers of women
taking in professions like doctor and
numbers that we wouldn't see again till
the 1980s there was just sort of this
really huge surge of of liberation for
the upper and middle-class women of
America going on right around the turn
of the century and then really in the
20s it kind of drew back and we
liberated our sort of our bodies and our
right to drink and drive cars and stuff
like that instead you know how about in
your the is college your maiden name her
married name married name
what was your maiden name Gleason did
you go back and look at the Gleason
family or your mother's family to find
out what happened to women in your own
family not really the Gleason family is
sort of one of those Irish none success
story really until my parents generation
so I don't think they were up to much of
note I remember vaguely might you know
grandmother talking's telling us stories
about Nursing soldiers during the Civil
War but there wasn't really a whole big
bunch of stuff going on until really my
parents generation where did you grow up
in Cincinnati for how long did you live
there until he's about 18 then I went to
and I never really returned from my
family still there I went there early on
to take the book around what were your
mother and father doing for a living my
father worked for the the utility
company he was an executive in the
utility company and my mother was a
traditional housewife I would say light
wrote the book partly for her I didn't
want this to be a book about how we were
stuck in the kitchen and then we got out
in 1970 and things have gotten better I
wanted from most of our history most
women wanted desperately to be full-time
housewives and that was the most
creative and empowering option that they
had way better than any of the jobs that
most of them could have hoped to have
gotten which were factory jobs and
farming jobs and domestic jobs so that's
been a junk of our history that that's
so important and that we you know it
took us a while to get back and look at
he's your mom and are they both still
alive yeah a mother was was there for
the beginning women the book parties
sort of moments and it was like her
mother rocked or everyone was I
dedicated the book to her mother so
she's had a big party then actually when
I was writing and I sent it to her and
said show me the parts that you think
are boring because it was about 800
pages when we finished it the first time
around and she was very very diligent
about chopping stuff out you know she
had no mercy so it was very good she was
big help now the family consisted of how
many people when your girl grew up I
have two sisters and a brother and was
the issue of what a woman who would do
in the society ever discussed around the
dinner table
not much know and that's the interesting
thing I was the oldest and I came at a
period when you know you still were kind
of thinking in terms of the 1950's
theory about women but my parents were
really ambitious for me and there was
there was never any real thought about
you know you couldn't do this or that
because you were a girl and you know my
sisters have both you know had some
stellar careers and what have they done
my one sister was a CPA and a financial
officer in California and my other
sister runs some nonprofit childcare
centers in Cincinnati that just do
stupendous work and childcare and she's
educated the whole women in education
thing is just a huge part of American
history
that both for the women who got the jobs
and for what happened to the country
because the women took the jobs that was
neat writing about you went where to
college I went to Marquette Milwaukee do
you have any experience there that well
you know that was the period of the
great even Marquette which was a very
conservative school you know and in the
late 60s was a period in which you were
supposed to not go to class we took to
the streets and we demonstrated for
freedom of speech and stuff like that so
there was a lot of stuff that we got to
do then that just happened because
that's the way the world was at the time
you know did you ever say I'm not going
to be a housewife like my mother no did
you ever think it that you I never
really thought I wouldn't and I think my
mother didn't think I would that there
wasn't really something that anybody
ever discussed it was just presumed that
I would go to college never I think ever
I thought I'd get married at some point
in time but it wasn't I didn't I don't
I've never felt like I've was a great
struggler for women's rights because in
fact people have been always
spectacularly supportive of me I've been
really really lucky and so it's other
people who carried the great banners
after Mark Kent what do you do well I
got married and I wouldn't went to
graduate school at at the University of
Massachusetts we had more demonstrations
closed down more schools had more days
with no classes and then my husband and
I went to Connecticut we both got
journalism jobs there my husband Dan's
an editor at CBS and then we went from
Connecticut to New York and Here I am
there's a picture in here that I want to
show this one right here because it more
often than not you would write about
what women had to wear yeah I think what
it what are we looking at here that's of
course that the period there's an entire
century worth of corseting going on in
in American history in which women could
barely breathe and you were supposed to
do it from the time you woke up in the
morning if you were middle-class
certainly you put on your corset when
you got out of bed
and the it was a time which one didn't
move around much I wrote in the book
about the bicycle at the turn of the
century and how important the bicycle
was to women because they've been
spending a century walking around in
these corsets with maybe 20 pounds worth
of skirts and petticoats hanging down
weighing them down
they were almost immobilized Clara
Barton during the Civil War couldn't
move sometimes because the blood would
soak into her petticoats when she was
nursing the soldiers and she was just
trapped you know to the floor and
suddenly you got the bicycle it was ok
for women to ride the bicycle so you
could soup along it was just an
extraordinary they called it wheeling
then you know it was an extraordinary
liberation moment for women and it all
the famous women of the time got on
bicycles you know Lillian Russell wrote
to a newspaper column explaining what
you wore when you went bicycling it was
just a very big moment the stuff about
what women wear their health issues
during are just so important for
American history you just tend to always
think that people got up in the morning
and did whatever they were supposed to
historically do you don't think about
well how did they feel physically did
they have any energy you know were they
in pain were they comfortable and that
stuff is just a huge part of the story
and that was one of the reasons I really
wanted to write the book I wanted to
kind of look at the stuff from the
ground up that what did you find a good
was some of your better sources on the
history of women their stupendous books
on the history of American women for the
last 20 25 years there's just been a
blossoming of the literature and what I
tried to do was to read as much of it as
I could I you know I have this wonderful
room now that's full of nothing but
books I had six assistants who worked
part time for me who read books and
underlying stuff for me and then I tried
to sort of pick out all the good bits
that I could and spin it into a story
that would be fun to read but would not
only tell the ground story and the big
over story but also some of the theories
that women have that historians have
developed about what women did and at
the end of the book I tried to show
through the footnotes where my trail was
so that
other people could follow it and go back
and read these books to the speaking of
the corsets you you also write that
there were periods where the larger the
woman was the better option
yeah the Gilded Age no I let's all go
back and live in the Gilded Age there's
this great letter from a guide in the
and toward the end of the century a 19th
century from the West saying a tightrope
walker came to town and she walked
across Main Street on her tightrope she
was the most beautiful woman I ever saw
huge thighs then Lillian Russell was the
great beauty of the time Lillian Russell
who you know on her good days weighed
about 160 pounds would have eating
contests with Diamond Jim Brady and
invite reporters would leave her corset
at with the maitre d when she came into
the restaurant so she'd have plenty of
room for the eating contest and that
everybody liked large I was a living
large kind of era people were proud then
of conspicuous consumption and and and
it was it was a period in which they
really celebrated the sins of the flesh
so what changed it to the opposite you
write in the 20s the flappers and the
skinny women and they went the opposite
you know after after suffrage that there
was sort of an explosion again in which
women wanted to be physically free and
they wanted they got rid of their
corsets they got rid of you know all the
restrictive clothing there was they wore
very simple straight outfits they wanted
to be able to walk around to be free to
move a lot the dances became really
Lively at that period of time yet the
Charleston was stuff like that and part
of the deal was that you wanted to be
physically free so you wanted to be
athletic you wanted to be able to move
around it was very strange though that
you know you had a period in which
boomer were supposed to be so physically
three but they they they bound their
breasts it was as if you couldn't get to
the point where women really opened up
to their bodies in a way than which
nothing was restrained so you were going
to be free you're gonna move around a
lot you weren't gonna be Kim didn't buy
corsets but you were gonna look like a
boy so it wouldn't be too threatening
physically to people
man reading this book also will find
some information about the woman's
biological functions that they probably
know that and I'm sure I mean this is we
don't need to go into any detail about
it but this must have been something
that you thought about writing before
you did it right right I know several
different periods where you write about
how the difference between men and women
and how they live their lives I am I
must say all was a person who tries to
imagine during the great moments of
history where people went to the
bathroom when all these things happen
you know where did they go the bathroom
when they were crossing the Great Plains
where did they get the privacy if they
got it I mean where they do about
diapers and what did women do when they
had their periods that and something
that every woman I know has always been
curious about so I had one researcher
who did virtually nothing to try to
figure that out I'm interested about
where do you find it there's not that
much informational what we found a lot
of it comes from letters from doctors
manuals and then once you hit the very
end of the 19th century advertisements
Sears catalog stuff like that you begin
to get some hints but parts of it are
still a mystery well it's because
there's so many characters in your book
let's say that you have the option of
putting the dinner together with some of
your favorite characters right table for
conversation pieces who would you start
with well I think you got to start with
Elizabeth Cady Stanton I mean for sort
of a person who's both smart and totally
wired into her society and very funny
and and just a person you could just
imagine sitting down with and listening
to her gossip about everybody that she
knew seven children yes and a drove
susan b anthony crazy you know one of
the great stories of the book is the
whole fight with the first time a
professional woman existed in the United
States she's writing letters about what
am I gonna do about children you know
about you know can I have a family what
am I gonna do about that and Elizabeth
Cady student B Anthony who was the great
partner Elizabeth Cady Stanton was
driven mad by the fact that she kept
having all these babies it was like a
betrayal of the cause every time it
happened but I would want to have her
for sure
she made my first person who else is at
that table um Lillian Russell is a
fascinating character I really and she
was a great suffragette too you know she
was very into women's voting and who was
she what she was well she was the great
beauty in the great theatrical performer
of the Gilded Age she sang and she did
comedies and somebody wasn't a great
dramatic actress what would you ask her
you know she would like to talk about
the fashions and the cosmetics and and
and all the physical things I she was
great about writing she would write
columnist for the newspaper about what
to do in order to look more beautiful
during those days they stressed thinking
beautiful thoughts more than in her
years she was she was in the gilded ages
after the Civil War so it was the 70s
and 80s and 1990s really she went on for
a very long time the third person at the
table a third person well I loved the
Grimke sisters I'm not sure if they'd be
great conversationalist but they really
knocked me out they were the daughters
of slave owners before the Civil War and
of all the white middle-class women in
the south they were the only ones who
said not only that they didn't like
slavery which wasn't that uncommon but
that they weren't going to take it and
they moved north at a time when women
never left home and traveled by
themselves and they began speaking on
behalf of the abolition movement to
mixed crowds of men and women which
never happened you never did that and
they did all these things they broke all
these rules and they didn't seem to
notice they just kind of trotted along
you know following their own star that
everyone was very thrilled when Angelina
who was a great spokesman for women's
rights got married because they thought
it was impossible you just didn't do
that she addressed the state legislature
was first time anybody did that she'd be
trotting along giving speeches well
crowds were you know throwing rocks
through the window they were just very
sweet
humorless kindly from where than from
they're from South Carolina we're in
South Carolina so Charleston and why are
they known in history I mean what was
the source of that and well we say that
oh that
there's there were several great
biographers of the Gertrude Lerner it
was the first of the Grimke sisters that
and there continued to be people writing
about them today they were just so
amazing at the end of the war they
retired and sort of lived on health
foods and and ran a boarding school and
suddenly there's a knock at the door and
these two young black men walk in and
say it turns out were your nephews your
brother you probably didn't know was
having an affair with our mother who was
his slave and we're free so we thought
we'd drop by and the Grimke sisters have
no money at all they're living on like
rice and apples and they say come in be
our nephews and we'll send you to
Harvard and they did and they became two
of the great you know civil rights
leaders of their era but they were just
they were just lovely women you just
would like to kind of hang out with them
for a while well including you we have
five at the table and we have room for
eight and the one of them has to be a
man and the man who did the most for
women in his lifetime so we've got two
more women to pick Wow the man who did
most for women in his lifetime you know
in some ways I would really have to
argue for Franklin Roosevelt on that
front but that means of course you'd
also want Eleanor I don't know if they
both want to come together certainly if
you have to Eleanor Roosevelt at the
table you got one laughs I got one left
um it seems like it would only be fair
to bring um oh you know who I'd love to
have I'd love to have one of the wasp
women from World War two but you know no
one in particular but these were women
who flew for the United States military
they flew in this country to free up
pilots to go overseas and the theory was
this was very safe and would be no
trouble at all they could do that with
their hands died but in fact the men
felt very strongly the while it was
glorious to die in battle it was really
stupid to die in schenectady at the
airport so they gave the women all the
dangerous jobs in this country like
towing targets for the airplanes and so
on and they risked their lives and the
so many of them died and taking up these
old rickety planes that were half
repaired and and they were just tossed
out once there were enough men they
didn't get any credit at all until the
90s I think they finally got
commissions but I'd love to have one of
them and just to talk about World War
two and what it was like back then let
me ask you about Franklin Delano
Roosevelt and you write about it it's
written a lot he's the guy that had the
affair though with another woman that
split that family up why would you want
to give him so much credit for women
getting advanced well you know what we
learned and we actually I wrote a book
about this the one before this the
scandal scorpion tongue was gossip
celebrity in American politics what we
learned again with Bill Clinton was that
American women like American men do not
care about what a president is doing in
his bedroom if they're getting the stuff
they want in terms of his policies and
the amount of the stuff that with
because of Eleanor but it was Franklin
who was president we have to always
remember the amount of stuff that
happened for women during that period
the number of changes that happen that
meant so much to women to rural women to
electrification alone for rural women
was probably the most important thing
that happened in the 400 years I write
about that suddenly you could bring
water into your house and that you'd
have lights on it you could listen to
the radio which was so crucial to these
women there's a great set of Diaries
during the depression of a woman in
Kansas who writes up you know writes her
diary every day you know fixed my
husband's pants and wrote to my daughter
who's away and you know and then Bob got
his divorce today and Bob is a character
in a soap opera but she's got them in
her diary right along with everybody
else because the soap operas are so
important to her life that bringing
voices into these lonely Plains farm
kitchens to East Texas to places like
that was so critical so if he only did
electrification it would have been
enough to get Franklin at the table I
think you do say in your book that
Eleanor Roosevelt was the most important
woman possibly the most important woman
in American history I think so you know
she was the first one and she had a
little bit of that same genius for that
rope-a-dope liberation thing I just what
she did she was able to do she created
so much of the New Deal really the heart
of the nude
the idea that government had an
obligation to make sure people were
taken care of and that they were okay in
this country that somehow the safety net
existed and it was government's
responsibility to do that always for
women politically the safety net has
been so important that was Elinor's
thought I think more than Franklin's
and she was the one who really pushed it
and who mobilized people around the
country behind these thoughts but she
always did it in terms of being a wife
you know she always had this sort of
fiction half fiction anyway that she was
only flying out to the Philippines to
see the troops because Franklin wanted
to go but he couldn't because he was
crippled and you know she was only going
down to the coal mine because Franklin
wanted her to go to tell him what was
going on and that helped the American
people accept this really dramatically
new vision of a woman in politics in
what she could do and and of course it
was the first administration that
brought a lot of women into high
positions in politics
you didn't mention other women that you
write about like Louisa Adams well you
found interesting why was she
interesting Louisa I ran into in my
first book and I found Louisa Adams was
John Quincy Adams wife and a difficult
guy at best and she had been when he was
ambassador to Russia she came back alone
across the frozen plains of Europe
during the Napoleonic Wars crossing
battle fields full of bodies with her
young child with her alone and yet when
she gets to Washington she's sitting
there writing she's eating chocolates
and writing her autobiography which is
called Adventures of a nobody and
there's a kind of duality to you know
Louisa who is just so extraordinary she
got her husband elected president
everybody hated John Quincy Adams but
she was quite a good hostess and able to
bring a lot of people around who
otherwise would probably have happily
tarred and feathered him so she had a
lot of power but yet on the other hand
she felt the obligation to feel very
powerless soon you didn't put margaret
sanger at your table no but she's
welcome to come though I'd love to have
margaret sanger my tent up enough room
for all these people you know I should
bring my mother too since she's figuring
so prominently and you know all this
stuff what would your mother do at that
table what would she is she quieter
have a grand time my mother just you
know sort of you know loves to be in the
mix of things and meet people and hear
what they're having to say and she's
she's very good at drawing people out
she'd have a great time side question do
your parents read your editorials um
they do sometimes yeah yeah you know and
they read my books and they read my
stuff are you on the same wavelength
politically that no not at all like many
parents in the world feel that
everything that I do is very good even
though it doesn't agree with whatever
they think other way they ever say to
you where did we go wrong only during
the 60s and the 70s when we were having
you know the rebellion against Vietnam
and the Free Speech Movement and things
like that the reason I brought up
Margaret Sanger is because a lot of your
book also is about the subject of sex
yeah
some up what's that that subject has had
on the history of women it's so I mean
obviously until we got really effective
birth control women we're not going to
be able to totally participate in the
public and commercial life of the
country just because they were
constrained by whatever happened to them
in terms of their bodies but it's also
true that like with as with work women
started writing their own rules way
before society decided that this was
going to be okay or that they knew how
to do it and from the time that from the
turn of the century at the beginning of
the 1800s you saw this dramatic drop-off
in the number of children per family you
know on and on and on throughout our
history until the 1950s really you had
this continual plummeting of the birth
rate which made it very clear that women
had figured out how to control the
number of births they had without much
help from either a science or or the
rest of society who was Margaret Sanger
well Margaret Sanger was of course this
nerd this very spunky Irish nurse whose
mother had way too many babies and who
came to Greenwich Village and lives
there very sort of radical bohemian life
with her husband until they had children
and then she went to work as a visiting
nurse and all was told this very
apocryphal story about a woman that she
treated who it had an abortion that went
wrong and
you know who begged her for some kind of
good birth control method and the doctor
then said we'll just have your husband
sleep on the roof have Jake sleep on the
roof and then the next time she saw the
woman saying or would always say you
know she was dying from another botched
abortion certainly for the immigrant
women and then she when she opened her
first clinic she just had miles and
miles and miles of poor immigrant women
standing there with their children you
know just dying for it wasn't so much
that there was not the science it was
that the information wasn't available
you didn't have any organized way of
finding out what worked and what didn't
and if you got lucky and got the right
deal you could be very effective but
until Margaret Sanger there was really
no way to really figure out what to do
what are there women that you got to
know or people who got to know in your
book that you wouldn't want at a dinner
party oh you know a lot of the
temperance women were really hard to
live with Frances Willard whoever was
the head of the the temperance movement
in America was was a remarkable woman
you really would want to have her at a
dinner party she was very smart she
wrote a book held how I learned to ride
the bicycle when she was in her 50s you
know she was one of those wheeling
ladies at that period and she was also
unique in that she brought the
temperance women together with the
suffrage movement for most women in
America the great social issue was not
getting the right to vote it was banning
alcohol that was their big deal and it
didn't really interest your average Main
Street homemaker so much the idea of
voting until it occurred to her that if
she could vote she could be in liquor
why did they want to ban liquor you know
from the very beginning in this country
from the very founding of the first
successful colony at Jamestown when the
first 200 settlers were all men you know
and the the investors come over to see
how the 200 men are doing and discovered
that they have got this rowdy fraternity
party going on in the woods there that
nobody's doing any work nobody's doing
any farming and they say what are we
gonna do here we got to bring in women
the women will make them settle down and
do the farming and get stuff done
job of women is to make men behave
that's been the under the bottom rule of
all of society and the making men
behaved thing was very much tied into
the idea of banning alcohol and also
shows you sort of the dark side of women
in power during that period women
there's always this sort of
surreptitious theory that women is
voters women as a political force are
the good people they want to you know
take care of the babies and stuff
whereas the men when I'm you know cut
taxes or go to war or whatever but when
women began to get political power the
first thing they wanted to do was to
enforce middle-class Main Street female
rules of behavior on the rest of society
now banned liquor
been any kind of sexual expression
whatsoever a ban pornography ban
gambling ban prostitution ban everything
that is you know a respectable matron in
Main Street would not like it was and
not any many of people who read the
books if I didn't really like that part
and go on to the next neat thing that we
did you know the temperance thing shows
that there's not women and politics have
not been perfect you didn't name Betty
Ford and to be there at the table yeah
you really should bring somebody from
the 70s one of the great leaders in the
70s and certainly she'd be a good choice
who's your favorite leader from the
seventies favorite leader from the 70s
um you know there's something really
appealing about Gloria steinem's ability
to kind of mix everything together and
and to create a package that was it was
so easy for large numbers of Americans
to accept but Betty Ford an figured out
a lot of stuff often the person who
you'd had that period there I think one
of the reasons that there was that
sudden explosion at that period was that
in the 60s for the first time you had a
mass of women who were in their 50s who
had raised their families who had been
permanent homemakers all their lives who
suddenly were likely to live for another
20 or 30 years and who really didn't
have that much to do because for the
first time you did have appliances
that in the absence of children took
care of many of the household chores
taking care of a home if there weren't
any children in it was not necessarily
something that was going to take up all
your time
and before that women had generally died
by the time their children roll out of
the house suddenly this was changed and
that I I think seeing their mothers for
younger women at that time and feeling
that kind of sudden can strange
liberation with no place to go for for
the older women was a big part of that
explosion and Betty Friedan was very
smart about kind of encapsulating all
that what year did the ER a get
introduced and what year was it defeated
and what was it the equal you know it's
very interesting the other day I was
someplace and I got an 11 year old girl
said why did the Equal Rights Amendment
failed I think God we've got an 11 girl
who wants to know about the Equal Rights
Amendment the Equal Rights Amendment
came right at the point when every
everything was exploding in the early
70s and there was a feeling when it was
first introduced that you would have it
would be passed into law in five seconds
you know and suddenly then it's stalled
and then it stopped and then it died off
and it was resuscitated and it died off
again and I always thought that the
reason it was all about symbols that the
stuff we thought the Equal Rights Men
was going to do all got done all those
little laws that people said you could
never get changed without one great
amendment all got changed we got the
stuff done that we needed to get done
the really serious business at hand
about giving women equal credit and
giving women equal job opportunities
things like that giving women the right
to sport to do sports on an equal level
with men but the symbol of the Equal
Rights Amendment was too many strid
ischl housewives it was it was simply a
statement that their lives didn't matter
and when you think of how fast things
changed when you think all those
centuries in which women had one job and
that's what they were supposed to do and
suddenly not only is that changing but
you have a lot of people in the women's
right movement saying traditional
housewives are stupid
they don't know what they're doing they
missed the boat their lives are really
you know not not fulfilled at all it was
inevitable that somewhere some symbol
was going to be picked and the world was
gonna say they were we were just gonna
say no that that hurts my feelings too
much I don't want to go there so in an
end in the end boy how could you not
feel some sympathy for them
er eh in the end missed by three states
yeah you think anybody to do that again
yeah I mean they talked about it once
well but it's really the deed is done
all the stuff is done you know to pass
an amendment to say that women have
equal rights in law when the laws have
already been changed and it just seems
like a great whole road to hoe for no
good reason well if you go back over
where we've been Revolutionary War the
Civil War World War One World War two
all had impact on women have we been
through a war now in the last couple
years that will again change woman's
life in this country yeah and everything
changes women's lives as it changes
men's lives but I don't think we'll ever
again have a situation because women go
to war now women are in the army it used
to be that much of what women had to do
was to take care of the homefront
because then we're going away but now
men and women go away we see this now in
Iraq you know that there are mothers
with children we have to go away because
they're in the reserves and serve for
long periods of time there so whatever
happens in the future is going to be
different it's not that the the rhythms
will be different from what we've seen
before but based on what you know with
all the laws that have been passed and
fifty five percent of the women and
graduated college I mean 55 some people
graduating college of women what about
the voters more women than men vote I
believe yeah more women than men do vote
that's been true for some so when is it
that women take over the majority of the
Corporations president United States
have 50% of the Senate on and on what's
your sense and I think a lot of those
things will happen in my lifetimes but I
doubt that you know they'll all happen
tomorrow is you know people rightfully
get very impatient you know there's lots
to be
but when I look at it in terms of 400
years just so much has happened so fast
I think you know you're going to need
another maybe generation of development
before we get to the point where there
are tons an equal number of women who
are not the husbands of powerful men
being politically and and and
economically as powerful as the most
powerful matter as the editor the
editorial page of the New York Times do
you ever sit there in your office or do
you think about as in that position I
have a responsibility to women do the
following no I think I have a
responsibility to women and two children
but yeah I and and you work you you
always feel that since you're there you
you have to be particularly open to
women's you know interests and needs and
complaints but I don't know that the my
predecessor Howell Raines was certainly
you know committed to women's rights and
to women's issues is and the other
members of the board are too in New York
Times we've long passed the Henry
arraignments the New York Times as
editorial board positions have been sort
of massively committed to women's rights
for a long time now if five of the
editorial positions on the board of the
fourteen there are women when are we
gonna see a majority you know they don't
turn over very fast and whenever I hire
somebody I must admit that although I
would love to have more women you know
there's there's all these other things
that come into the mix and and you're
always trying to make the mix more
fruitful so sometimes all the different
variables don't come up at the same time
but I get yelled at a lot by women about
that so I'm certainly very conscious of
it and how did you manage to write a
book in the middle of your other
responsibilities when did you do it I
did it late at night I'm a late at night
kind of person and on weekends
and it's like cited about half of it was
done before I got this particular job
and so I and I also had no life did you
find another woman in the book that you
would write a book about a biography
about um not right now I found so many
wonderful by
of of women that I got to read from this
I've just done all the scholarship
that's out there I must admit this exact
moment in time I have no desire
whatsoever to write another book I'm
just thrilled that this one's done and
out and having a life of its own yeah
another person that you mentioned that
was in a pivotal spot was Billie Jean
King yeah why thank you know when we in
this in the 70s when there was suddenly
a realization that women could do sports
and often you have a silly or a non
remarkable moment that happens in
history that you kind of focus on it's a
oh my god and that that moment in which
Billie Jean King beat Bobby Riggs at
tennis even though she was a top player
and he was a very sort of
middle-of-the-road
you know struggling tour guy
it just focused the American mind on the
idea that women could do sports and that
women athletes could be could be not
only really good at their games but
really sort of fun to watch and
characters you'd like to invite to a
dinner party but that they weren't you
know there wasn't something off-putting
or strange about them that they were
your friends and their daughters and
your wives and your sisters and so on
what is your instinct you're in the
state with a famous American woman
politician Hillary Rodham Clinton who
everybody says will be a candidate at
least in 2008 maybe even in 2004 do you
have a responsibility to boost her up to
that job no I don't think you know
that's interesting women voters don't
feel that responsibility do you see in
the polls if there's a woman candidate
who's particularly attractive sometimes
you do see you know women kind of
flocking to her to be supportive of her
but none of the polls seem to indicate
that women prefer to see women running
for office over men they'll vote for a
man over a woman if they like the man
better so no I don't think that that but
you know it's interesting one thing I
did when I was on the bus with Hillary
her Senate campaign and I've never been
able to prove this is right or not it
may be a big misunderstanding in my
property you would see these women
upstate sort of middle-aged women and I
just really really really excited about
Hillary Clinton and I just had the
feeling that that there's maybe a group
of women out there women who had raised
their families and had careers but they
gave up part of the careers for the
families and they were happy to have
done the families and they were happy
with the careers but suddenly the kids
are grown and they're thinking maybe I
could have a real shot not just at
continuing my good career but really
doing something spectacular maybe I
could start all over again and do some
really neat thing and that for those
women Hillary Clinton was a really
special person and I do think that
there's just something there there's
just a vibration that goes on sometimes
the title of your book 400 years of
dolls drudges helpmates and heroines was
whose idea we wrote it together but it
was the susan b anthony is responsible
for the dolls and the dredges she always
said that if you got married if you
married a rich man you were a doll and
you married a poor man you were a dredge
and then we threw in the helpmates and
the heroines which began with H's but
also most women in this country have
either been supporting men or they've
stood out on their own and done sort of
amazing things and that was the
helpmates than the heroines we're out of
time Gail Collins title of her book is
women America's women thank you very
much for joining thank you